Robb's world hey what's up guys it's rob
and welcome to my tutorial for the mini
magic ball the magic balls are sometimes
called dragon's eggs because of the way
they look and I think they're based off
of the classic waterbomb base the
origami magic balls were created by yury
and Catrin shoe McCall it's called the
mini magic ball because it has a lot
fewer folds than the regular one that I
have here it's a great stress reliever
that you can squish compressed like this
into a flower and stretch it out and
then you could turn it on to the other
side flip it inside out and do the same
providing hours of fun since the
majority of people in my ninja star cube
video and over 90% of people in my time
lapse video wanted to see it let's do it
I would like to thank everyone who
commented on my time lapse video for the
mega magic ball the exact time that it
took me to make was 2 hours 13 minutes
and 39 seconds and only one person out
of over 500 comments not the exact hour
and minute which is really impressive
and it was user wall-e does so
congratulations great job dude also the
highest rated comment from my secret
subtitle was by Justin I will show some
other gifts is that were really close
and some of my other choice comments
later on be sure to look out for some
secret subtitles and comment for your
chance to be featured also don't forget
to rate share and subscribe and click
that notification bell if you do enjoy
it although there are ways to make the
mini magic walls without tape it's a lot
more challenging and I'd like to show
you the easiest way I know first I'm
going to be using a single sheet of
eight-and-a-half by 11 printer paper but
if you want to use an 11 by 17 sheet
just like this or even take 2 pieces of
origami paper together that's fine also
so grab your sheet of paper and let's go
to turn your paper into 1 to 2
proportion rectangle like this with two
connected squares first fold it in half
like this lining up the edges perfectly
and making nice sharp creases set the
paper so that the vertical fold is a
mountain fold and then fold the corners
into the vertical midline like this and
then we could tear off the excess paper
on the bottom now that you have a paper
like this we're gonna flip it over and
fold these top two corners down to the
bottom also once again making a nice
crease along the outside and do the same
with the upper left corner your paper
should now be twice as long as it is
wide with each square having an X in it
now your paper will be too
in half along this vertical middle line
that is a mountain fold also having two
x's on each side that I have marked with
the dot because this side is going to be
the outside or color side of the magic
ball the next thing we're going to do is
to slip the paper into 16 vertical
sections just like this so let's go
ahead and do that take one end of the
paper and fold it on this vertical line
just like this across and then we're
going to hold it like this so that's the
two edges that are open are on the top
and take the top edge and fold it down
all the way to the bottom again line it
up as neatly as possible and then make a
crease along the top running your
fingernail against it flip it over and
do the same exact thing fold the top
edge down and crease sharply now when
you open up the paper you see we split
the paper into quarters and we're going
to take these two folds now and fold
them directly into the middle so just
pinch that fold on the right side and
just slide it right into the middle line
and make a crease here all the way
throughout the paper and if you lift up
the outside right edge you'll see we
created a new fold here and let's do the
same with the left side slide the edge
directly into the middle and crease all
the way down the paper now your paper
will look something like this
and we're going to take the outside
edges and also fold them directly into
the middle so just take the edges one at
a time and fold them directly to the
midline just like this you do ooh now
you'll see we split the paper into eight
vertical sections as you'll see the
paper now has three Mountain folds and
four valley folds we're going to rotate
the paper and fold downwards on the
valley folds so crease downwards on all
of the valley folds across the paper
just like this once you've done that
open the paper once more and turn it 90
degrees like this and take this first
Mountain fold and slide it directly to
the middle line just pinch the mountain
fold like this and slide it down and
once it's lined up then make a crease
directly in the middle of this next
section here all the way across and that
basically creases the section in half as
you could see under here then we could
take the next section and split it in
half by taking this mountain fold and
doing the same thing so just take that
next mountain fold and fold it down
right on top of the previous one we just
put in the middle then let's flatten the
paper out
just keep doing that fold this one in
just like this and then finally fold the
very last edge into the middle trying to
be as neat as possible
now when you unfold everything you'll
see half of the paper is in sixteenths
and now we could rotate the paper and do
the same thing with the other half just
like before take the mountain folds and
continue to bring them in to the middle
just like this take the last one and
just bring it down and then once you're
done with that we could take the outside
edge and finally fold it into the middle
once again give it a nice sharp crease
now we've split the paper into 16
vertical sections eventually we will be
turning the vertical folds into mountain
folds now that we've divided it
vertically we can split it into eight
horizontal sections first we're going to
flip it on to the other side that's not
the color side just like this and just
flatten everything out then take the top
edge and fold it down to the bottom edge
and once they're aligned we can crease
along that new top fold then you can
just crease the paper and open it up and
we're going to take the top and the
bottom edges and fold it directly onto
the horizontal midline just like this
when you do that just make sure that
each of the lines here lines up with the
rest of the fold
flip it upside down and then do the same
with the top and as you'll see that line
that I drew is matching up with the
other side you can unfold the paper and
flip it back over so that you have
something that looks just like this all
horizontal creases are now Mountain
folds here is the horizontal midle line
and again we're going to take the first
Mountain fold here and fold it directly
in here by pinching it and sliding it
down directly into the middle and then
make a crease all the way across take
the outside edge and fold it down into
the middle also taking your time and
being as neat as possible and lining up
all the creases so fold it down line it
up and make a crease and now you flip it
around and do the same exact thing bring
the mountain fold directly into the
middle and flatten it out and then do
the same with the outside edge so if you
did that you should see an X with a
little bit of a box in the middle so now
again just run your fingernail against
the top and then we're basically just
going to fold the whole thing in half
just like this so that it's kind of like
a fan when you open up the paper you'll
see that we've split it into eight
different horizontal sections and
sixteen different vertical sections to
make the next step easier we're going to
make each of those vertical folds into
mountain folds so just take the paper
like this and fold it on each of these
creases just like that downwards to make
sure they're each Mountain folds so just
keep folding down and creasing on each
one of the 16 sections to make sure that
it has a nice crease to finish the pre
creases we need to make X's in every
single one of the boxes that we have on
the paper I'm also going to draw some
boxes just to make things easier for you
to see to turn this into this we need to
make all of the diagonal pre-creases
going this way and then all of the ones
going this way I'm just going to draw
dots here so that it can help you
visualize what you need to be looking at
when you're making those creases so as
you'll see I drew dots at each of the
intersection going this way and all of
the intersections are going this way
what you're going to first do is to take
the corner here and fold it to this dot
then you're going to take it and go to
this stuff this stuff this that all the
way through we're going to do the same
going this way start by taking the
corner and folding it into the first dot
so that this edge and the
sedge art lined with this one and this
one respectively
just like this when you do that just
make a nice sharp crease and as you'll
see not only are this edge and this edge
lined up with those two lines that we
drew with this diagonal line she'll also
be in line with the one that we have
here then you can open it up and then
fold it into the second one make a nice
sharp crease at this point you'll see
that this horizontal line should be in
line with this one and this one should
be in line with this one so there's just
a couple of things that you need to see
when you do that just to make sure
everything is lined up nice and neat
then you can open it and do the next one
so fold it in to the third one then we
can continue to fold the corner down to
each intersection until we get down to
the bottom here and make sure there's a
nice crease on the fourth one just make
sure everything is lined up so now let's
speed it up a little bit just continue
to fold the corner down to each dot on
the diagonal line until you get down to
the bottom when we get down to the
bottom you'll see we've already made
this diagonal fold across so we just
need to put the corner down and flatten
it out then we could fold the bottom
left corner to each one of these points
on this diagonal line I just like to
flip the paper over because it's easier
for me but you can do it whichever way
you like fold the corner to each
intersection of the boxes that I marked
be as neat as possible lining up the
grid and making nice sharp creases now
you should have something that looks
like this however we have not finished
all the pre creases that go in this
direction you've only done up to here
the corners so we just need to do the
seven remaining ones in the middle so
I'll draw on the ones that we've already
done so you can see at this point once
your paper looks like mine you'll see
that we've done the creases all the way
down to the corners so like I said we
just need to do the seven remaining ones
directly in the middle if you look
closely you'll see that this edge folds
directly on to the midline so all we
need to do is to shift the edge directly
to the left on this next vertical line
so just shift that edge to the next or
adjacent vertical line and then we can
make a crease on the outside again
following the same guidelines that these
horizontal lines are continuous with the
rest of the horizontal line on
left side of the paper at this point
you'll notice that you have one row
that's overhanging on the bottom with
this line coinciding with the very
bottom edge of the paper
once you have it lined up like that just
make a nice sharp crease all the way
throughout and crease it with your
fingernail so it's going to go to the
next one over now you have two rows on
the bottom the second line here should
coincide with the bottom so make sure
all those lines are basically lined up
if you look at the bottom very closely
you'll see that these diagonal fold
should coincide with the ones that are
already on this part of the paper as you
can see right here so now we can crease
it and you'll see at the bottom we have
two rows hanging off then we can
continue to shift the edge over until
there's four overhanging rows so just so
you can see I'm going to draw on the
last four that we just did and continue
to fold to these points now turn it over
like this and once again we're going to
take this corner and fold it all the way
down to the bottom of the paper since we
did four on this side we know that we
have three more left to do because there
are only seven in between the ones from
corner to corner so we just have to
basically get it down to here so we just
need through it three more times there's
one there's two and three and there you
go you finished all the diagonal folds
going this way and again I'll draw on it
so that you could see which ones we've
done so now you'll see we've done all of
the diagonal folds that are going in
this direction a good way to check to
see if you miss any fold is to look on
the back because Mountain folds are a
lot easier to see than Valley folds at
this point you should have a piece of
paper that looks like this with all of
the diagonal pre creases in this
direction completed we're now going to
do the diagonal pre creases in this
direction by taking these corners and
folding them inwards this way once we
get to the midline here or at this point
here we're then going to do the same
thing that we did in the other direction
so let's go ahead and do that just like
in the other direction fold the corner
to each one of the dots on the line
intersections all the horizontal and
vertical folds should meet up keep
folding until the corner reaches the
very bottom of the paper now I'm going
to flip it over
and do the same with this corner once
again folding the corner down to each
one of the intersections and aligning
the edges unfold so now I will draw on
the pre creases that we just made we now
have seven more pre-creases to make in
this direction so just like before I'm
going to put the corner down and shift
it over to each one of these points
again making sure that all of the
creases align and that I have four rows
overhanging on the bottom once again now
that there's four overhanging rows on
this side we could flip it over and then
we're going to fold this corner down so
that there's three overhanging rows
great job we just did all the pre
creases and every box should have an
accident so as you'll see I have a grid
of eight boxes by sixteen boxes and
every single one has an X in it it's
quite easy to see this when you flip it
over as well you need to be very
familiar with the waterbomb and that the
diagonal folds in it are very sharp Ally
folds we're also going to be dealing
with something I call the double
airplane base that looks something like
this and they're going to be connected
in this fashion in this larger scale you
can see how the two bases connect and
that they'll flatten out and collapse
like so you're going to have to be very
familiar with this pattern that has a
waterbomb followed by a double airplane
base then next to another water bomb
that's connected to a double airplane
base in the columns you'll see that the
water bombs are actually connected to
each other there are also staggered or
offset which creates a zigzag pattern if
you follow along and pay close attention
with some practice you'll definitely get
it although the lines I drew on the
paper show all the pre creases that we
now folded not every fold is necessary
to collapse the ball so to avoid
confusion I outlined on this sheet the
folds that we will need to collapse to
make the magic ball remember this side I
am holding up will be the outside or the
color side of the magic ball it's up to
you but you may want to go over the
diagonal creases in both directions and
also the mountain folds just because
it'll make it a little bit easier to
collapse the model we're going to fan
out the model by first folding upwards
by Valley folding in the first crease
and then mountain folding and
alternating all the way till you get
down to the bottom when you look at it
from the side you'll see that you have
four V's connected to each other with
alternating Valley folds and mountain
folds we will start working on the mini
magicball layer two layer first creating
a water bomb in the upper right portion
of the paper we need to complete the top
layer and to do that we need to reverse
fold or tuck in this upper right
valley-fold here like this and then
squeeze these two edges together with
really sharp pre-creases this shouldn't
be too challenging directly next to it
will be a double airplane base as you
can see here so we basically just open
up these two edges and we're going to
push downwards on this horizontal fold
just like this when you do that you'll
see that these two corners will fold
upwards towards this mountain fold and
then you could just pinch it just like
that again next to the double airplane
fold will be another water bomb base so
you can just kind of tuck this in like
this and just give it a nice squeeze
like this again we're going to have
another double airplane base so just
open it up like this and just push
downwards here it's also good to have a
feeling for where your finger is on the
back of the model like right here so
that you can also push from the back
just like that you can just push
downward and do the same thing hold
upwards on this corner and fold upwards
on this corner you'll see when you
flatten everything out you have
basically completed the first layer of
the magic ball looking at it from the
front view like this you'll notice that
we have a half a waterbomb the airplane
folds here another half of a waterbomb
and the airplane fold you'll also notice
that there are four distinct sections in
the paper with the section below the
airplane base being kind of lifted up
and the section below this top portion
of the water bomb collapsed into a
valley fold and you'll also see that it
looks like a why the same thing with
this airplane and this half water bomb
that we have here on the bottom you can
more easily see the Y which have
Mountain folds below them while beneath
the airplane folds are sort of boxed out
like this now that you understand the
basics let's move on here again is the
double airplane base so we're just going
to squeeze it and also tuck this corner
in
this we have a why here and the Y's are
going to turn into X's or waterbomb
bases to do this we're just going to
open it up like this and push from
behind on this horizontal crease like
this give it a little squeeze and then
you can kind of collapse it like that
then again we're going to work on the
next water bomb here the Y so to do that
we're going to lift it up just like this
and give it a nice squeeze you'll see
that we have an X a Y and X and a Y if
you flip it over a good thing to do is
to take your finger and just basically
follow it up to the end of the Y to make
sure that these creases are nice and
sharp so if it's popped out just make
sure that it's like this and then just
walk your finger all the way up now when
you flip it over you'll see again we
have an X Y X Y and we're going to start
from the left side now this Y is going
to turn into an X so just open up these
two edges
Pince it here and then you can collapse
it so we're basically alternating
between the first and third Y's to turn
into X's and the second and fourth Y's
to turn into X's since we did the first
one here let's do the third one open it
up lift it up from behind and then
squish it now we're going to be working
on the second and fourth one just lift
it up like this and give it a pinch then
again we're going to do the second one
so just open up these two edges here
push from behind give it a little pinch
here and then basically collapse the
model just like this now we're going to
be working on the first and the third
one so again this is also the double
airplane base so we're going to tuck
this in just like that and then we're
going to turn it into a water bomb base
so just lift it up from behind and just
squish it like that then we're going to
turn this one here into a water bomb
base as well by squishing it down like
that now we're going to turn this one
into a water bomb base and then we're
going to turn the one in the second row
into a water bomb base I'm going to
speed up a little bit because it is the
same process but I will slow down when
we get to the end because it is a little
trickier continuing on
going to turn this Y into an X by
pushing from the back just like this and
then collapsing it now going to section
three by pushing also in the back and
squishing it down turn this Y into X the
same way and then on section two squish
it down now we're going to turn this Y
into an X the same way as you'll see it
doesn't want to fold that way so just
take your fingernail and run it along
the X and that should allow you to
squish it down by pushing it down like
that now let's go on to section three by
pulling it apart and lapsing it just
like that as you'll see this one here it
doesn't want to fold all the way on this
diagonal so again like I said before
just flip it over and all you need to do
is to take your hand and walk it up on
this mountain fold all the way up to the
bottom of the Y and that will basically
make nice creases and you could do that
every time if you want in order to make
sure that it folds in the proper creases
just compress the model again and you'll
notice that we have the X Y X Y so we're
just going to do the same thing and
collapse this fourth one and then the
second one then once again we will do
the first one by tucking that in and
collapsing it just like this and then
doing the third one pinch it and
collapse it then we can once again do
the second and fourth ones so here we're
just going to push on the back here and
collapse it and then again do the second
one by opening the edges and squishing
it down then once again collapse it and
move on do the same thing by compressing
each of these Y's into X's until we get
to this part here and now I'll go
through how to finish collapsing the
mini magical we're almost done
collapsing the mini magic wall and at
this point it makes it easier if you
kind of hold it like this by basically
grabbing it on these water bombs on the
bottom here and what we're going to do
is the same thing we're going to turn
this Y here into an X by lifting up on
this crease here like this and just
collapsing it then again just kind of
hold it like this and you'll see we have
another Y right here so just push up
right on this little crease just like
that
try to open it a little bit more if it
gets stuck and then you can kind of
crease it down now again see how it got
stuck well that's because it's not
creasing the way it's supposed to
remember it needs to fold on these
diagonals so just push right here and
you'll see that will kind of turn into a
Y just like that okay and then we could
basically just kind of hold it and push
it together just like this
now the last ones that we need to do
well remember the Y's need to turn into
X's or water bombs and then here are
going to be the airplane folds so let's
start with the right side we're going to
turn this into a water bomb to do that
this corner here needs to get folded up
like that what we're going to do is just
take it and fold it up like this and
that will not only finish the water bomb
but it will also create the double
airplane vase here now we're going to
create another double airplane base here
by taking this corner and folding it up
as well all right and then we're going
to do the same here by taking this and
folding it up and that will create the
water bomb here so we have the water
bomb and then the double airplane base
and then finally we're going to take
this corner and fold it up and now
you've completed collapsing the mini
magic ball now that we've finished
collapsing the magic ball we need to
change it into something that looks like
this
and then finally into this so that we
can connect it together and finish the
magic ball the first step will be to
undo or untuck these edges or inside
reverse folds I included them in the
collapsing process because it makes it
easier to visualize the water bombs so
hold the magic ball just like this with
the water bomb here in the upper right
and what we're going to do is just
untuck it here and flatten it down just
like that then continue down by
untucking and flattening it like this
untuck and flatten and then keep going
[Applause]
if you open it you'll see this side of
the model should basically look like
there's eight V's connected to one
another just like that now we're going
to flip it around and we're going to do
the same thing with this corner we're
just going to untuck it or unfold it
like this and then we're going to untuck
these edges or inside reverse folds as
well so just the same thing untuck it
like this and flatten it out and then
just do the rest
and finally just unfold this corner that
we had folded in so on this side you
should see that it's basically eight
mountain folds that are connected to
each other one side will start and end
with Mountain folds with the other side
starting and ending with Valley folds
like this to turn this into this we need
to reverse fold each one of these
mountain folds and fold this corner down
just like this so let's go ahead and do
that hold it with the side starting with
the valley folds and we're going to take
this corner and fold it down now we're
going to reverse fold this mountain fold
by just taking it and pushing downwards
along this line and this crease here now
it's not already creased that way so you
kind of have to force it up just a
little bit do the same with the
remaining mountain folds by tucking them
in and pinching them so it looks
something like this and continue all the
way down by doing the same thing
completing the reverse folds and then
again when you get to the end here just
take this corner and fold it down like
this once you fold that corner down and
collapse it it should look something
like this now that we folded down the
corners and reverse fold at each one of
these edges we're going to do the same
on the other side it's a little
different because we just have Mountain
folds here so all we need to do is to
reverse fold each one of these edges in
so let's go ahead and do that tuck it in
and pinch
[Music]
and now you're done with all of the
folds for the mini magic ball now that
you reverse hole did all the edges and
fold it down the corners on the other
side you should be able to compress the
model just like this before we join the
two edges of the magic ball together
like this just make sure that all the
creases are nice and sharp and that
nothing is stuck if you have something
like this where it's kind of stuck then
you want to just correct it by just
putting your finger in here and then
giving it a little bit of a pinch
alright guys congratulations you've done
all of the precreasing and collapsing so
now you're all done you finished the
origami peacock tail and the origami fan
also the origami bar bells
alright so seriously all we need to do
now is to basically tape the two ends
together if you'll look at it you'll see
that it is symmetrical so when you join
the two ends together it will meet off
and you'll be able to stick them
together like that all we need to do is
to kind of pick one end it doesn't
really matter at this point so just take
the corner here and the other corner and
we're going to gently pull them apart
like this and we're going to try to
flatten it out now don't get a little
worried here because I know we did work
hard on the collapsing part it will Rika
lapse on it going to memorize what it
looks like of course and also squeeze it
really hard like this so that the memory
is in the paper and press it down and
squeeze really hard then you could open
up the end like this and the other end
and just gently pull on them like that
and we're just going to flatten it out
by just pressing on any of these folds
that are kind of sticking up
then I can do that with the other side
so just take it just kind of pull it
apart and just press gently on any of
these folds like this and just kind of
get that edge nice and flat like this
then we're going to take the tape and
just take it off the roll like this and
we're going to take it and put it on the
inside of the mini magic ball on this
side here as you'll see the tape is
about the width of one of the boxes so
we're actually just gonna put it halfway
because we are going to join the two
ends together so just leave a little bit
overhanging and stick it about halfway
on this box here like that once it's
halfway and lined up parallel like this
then you can kind of stick it on and
just gently pull off the rest of the
tape and just walk it down like this on
the edge then you could rip off the end
of the tape like this and then we're
just going to gently press down on this
so it's kind of folded back in that
round shape and just do the same with
the other edge like this so it's just
still flat but just bolt downward now we
could join the two edges together we
should I take the corner and just make
sure it is pressed downwards here as you
see it came apart so we're going to
stick it like this make sure it's nice
and flat here and as you'll see the
memory will still kind of be in the
paper and just remember what the creases
are in the paper so again this is the
double airplane base then we can take
the two ends and we're just going to
take the corners here it doesn't matter
which end you use just start with one of
them and join up the two ends on the
tape like this press the corners
together and just gently walk your
finger down on the edge
the rest of the folds and the edges like
this and just gently pressed down until
you're about halfway like that then you
could take the other corner and put it
on top of the other edge like this and
join up the corners and just gently
press on it like this again we are going
to be pressing on the inside here so
just press and just make sure that
everything has kind of touched the tape
and as you'll see it will start
collapsing in the way it should but some
of it might get stuck so keep working on
it giving it a nice press on the tape
just like this and making sure all
points are touching you can kind of fold
this excess tape on the other side what
we have here is we have a little house
and if you kind of turn it like this
you'll see the Y is still here and it's
all in valley-fold so that's what we're
gonna have here we're gonna have a
little Y in Valley folds like this and
then this edge here is going to be
inside reverse fold to make a little
point and then you can kind of pinch
that point together just do that for the
rest of the top of the paper here so so
another inside reverse fold and upside
down Y and then you could pinch these
edges together gonna be a little harder
on the tape but you'll eventually get
any area where you're gonna have this X
here you're just gonna push in the
middle like that and that will kind of
collapse the waterbomb again again here
on the X so we're just going to press
here and that will allow it to collapse
and press gently like this again here on
the top we have the house and has
upside-down Y in valley-fold so again
next to here is gonna have an
upside-down Y which it does already and
then there's gonna be an inside reverse
fold here in just the two edges together
and as you'll see it's kind of coming
together again here we're just gonna
have the upside down house with the Y so
this is going to be inside reverse
folded like this and the house is gonna
come together like that just make sure
these edges are touching on the tape
then you can inside reverse fold this
part if the edges become unstuck then
press them harder to the tape in order
to better adhere them just make sure all
the creases are going the way that they
need and you'll eventually be able to
kind of collapse it like this you should
see eight points here from these little
houses on the top and also the bottom
and all of the water bombs should again
be formed and here's where the tape is
you can kind of just give it a nice
squeeze like this to make sure the edges
are touching on the tape like that and
there you go it's all collapsed and all
we need to do is to break it in now to
break in the mini magic bowl I first
like to collapse it press
and squishing it back and forth just
like this then I like to push on top
until it turns inside out you'll notice
when you do that it flattens and forms a
lip or Ridge on the top then you can
transform it into an eight-pointed star
just like this with a smaller eight
pointed star inside you need to crease
these outside points by pinching them
one at a time
once you have the flower shape you can
then stretch it by pulling on outside
points to open or inflate the ball again
you need to pull up and out on the
outside of the opposite inside points to
reinflates the ball at this point we
need to fix any folds which may have
been collapsed unfolded or crushed and
then we could squish or collapse back
together like we did when we first
connected it at the ends once it's
broken in then you can try turning it
inside out just like this but be careful
not to rip it and there you go you have
finished your mini magic ball amber
rooster and avery 21 both guests 2 hours
and 10 minutes tops two months for
guessing the exact time on my stop
chicken no this Apple gamer oh eight and
Julianne all got to fifteen while
Edinboro got two hours and seventeen
here are the comments I picked and the
secret subtitles
so we may have a possible hostile
intruder in Sector and you're gonna work
on it locked on Intel says it's made of
paper
sorry sir we've lost it